well welcome to CBS this morning we got
a lot of news to tell you turkey's top
diplomat confirms his government has not
given the u.s. any recordings of the
alleged murder of Washington Post
contributor Jamal khashoggi Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo had already denied
that telling reporters I've heard no
tape I've seen no transcript the New
York Times reports major general ahmed
al assyria top intelligence official
with close ties to Saudi Arabia's Crown
Prince may get the blame for the alleged
killing we sure Jang is at the White
House where the Trump administration is
taking some steps against the Saudi
leadership we do good morning good
morning Jon good morning to everybody
Turkish officials claimed Khashoggi was
murdered inside the Saudi consulate in
Istanbul and are reportedly expanding
the search for his body to a large
forest in the city
this comes after president Trump moved
closer to acknowledging the Saudis may
have played a role we should be able to
get to the bottom very soon on his way
out west for campaign rallies President
Trump was asked if Jamal khashoggi is
dead it certainly looks that way to me
it's very sad the president said if
Saudi Arabia is to blame it will face
consequences
mr. Trump added he's waiting for the
results of three different
investigations before drawing
conclusions I told President Trump this
morning that we ought to give them a few
more days Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
briefed President Trump at the White
House after a trip to Saudi Arabia and
Turkey
he said Saudi officials promised a
transparent probe there are lots of
stories out there about what has
happened we just are going to allow the
process to move forward but the
administration seems to be toughening it
stands on Thursday Treasury secretary
Steve minuchin announced he's ditching a
financial summit in Riyadh writing on
Twitter after meeting with the president
and Pompeyo
we have decided I will not be
participating ma Newton's withdrawal
marks the first formal rebuke of the
Kingdom over the Khashoggi case a
contrast to mr. Trump
recent comments praising Saudi Arabia as
a key ally in countering Iran and
ordering american-made weapons on CBS n
last year Khashoggi warned the Trump
administration's embrace of Saudi
leadership could backfire
is it the Trump effect that felt that
that made Prince Mohammed bin Salman
feel empowered to this impulsive
behavior in in foreign policy it is
dangerous it's dangerous for Saudi
Arabia for the region sources tell CBS
News the results of the Saudi
investigation will be made public by
Sunday but human rights groups are
calling on the United Nations for an
independent investigation arguing Saudi
officials cannot be trusted to deliver
credible results since they are
investigating themselves Norah all right
we thank you